you see that I love what you are
sometimes man I think you're a
mysterious figure do you really do so
you don't you think that I could be I
think you're hard to figure out
sometimes but do you think that I'm
playing for the for the evil side
no dude well you think what you think
I'm dark arts yeah yeah you don't think
I'm a part of the dark art no I do not
yeah you know can I say about you miner
yeah I think you're on my team
what is it the team light team like yeah
yeah we don't we don't do a dark arts
you don't no we don't we don't yeah yeah
yeah we don't
I can see that yeah I can see us not
doing them yeah yeah we you know you
don't in any other time period yeah you
and I would been like Schindler really
yeah we would help people I think I
thought how would I do a lot of the work
and you would have been kind of kind of
complaining off to the side but I think
what you're saying is if we were Nazi
German you and I are Germans and we
wanted to help some Jews yes and we're
trying to smuggle 50 out of a camp that
I would carry too and you carry 48 I
think I'd be put in charge or more of
them yeah that's so [ __ ] rude it's so
rude well here's what he's no no I'm to
see this dude alright I would probably
not do as much as you okay but I would
do a lot of work you know because I you
you gave me a look like you doubt me
here's the thing I'd put you in charge
of the snacks I would be in charge of us
a lot of leading us a direction you be
in charge of the bread bag crayons
something else yes how about this could
I be in charge of like like escape plan
mm-hmm would I be asking will you give
me some of that responsibility yes you
are an idea man you execute a guy behind
the guy saying okay good I was getting
offended there ya know so I would have
liked a little like hey do idea this is
where the fence is yeah right this is
where you dig the hole yeah this is
where you the Goldbergs gonna whatever
their name is are right yeah I'm gonna
sneak out right but you do it I'll say
that to you you do a TL I would go
beyond the framelit I'll be on the train
I'll wait for ya
and you wouldn't be able to go
undercover probably not
in this you have to be agent in this
we're both ourselves you know right
we'll tonight because the Germans were
in cahoots with our buddy
nothing could be German Japanese yes I'm
jabbing Herman yeah jumping get Berman
yeah yeah you read your permit I'm sure
Pearlman yeah oh who is this yeah so
alright well then that's the deal then
but I think that the in terms of the
light we would do like [ __ ] yeah I could
probably see us doing some pretty
positive stuff dude you know I could see
you doing some stuff probably building
toys for like a yard or something like a
school yard or something teeter-totter
man doing teeters you know building
teeters you don't see it no but I don't
you mean for like building a building
like a little wooden like little I mean
they're they're toys or reliable toys
which I know but you're not making any
shoddy [ __ ] toys killed what you're
saying though to me he's put a lot of
trust in the toys yeah but in like your
[ __ ] bar in a concentration camp and
that's what I'm [ __ ] doing here just
making toys bro bro this is for the I
know I'm making a seesaw on the
concentration camp is that you're saying
that as taut as they call them yeah do
you [ __ ] you know you're building
totters for kids man local kids are
gonna play no matter what kids will play
anywhere that's true you put a kid in
the seventh circle of hell I'm gonna
[ __ ] play dominoes you don't I'm
saying kids are they're just built into
them that you know kids will play no
play that's what they like to do you
know when you just set that it's just
strung up something inside my what was
it I think I want children I wanna be
some conversation before here a little
bit yeah they talk about yeah yeah but I
don't you want kids man you know what's
so funny man I was just thinking about
it you know I'm just thinking about it
now is like the time of trying to figure
that out or or not what do you what do
you forty I'm 38 are you almost 40 not
that close to 45 died that I'm never
gonna be 40 yeah but you're alright
you're 38 so who wins that you do
but at the age of 38 I think that you
know anything it's about time what the
[ __ ] do you tell them you don't have any
[ __ ] kids you got a beautiful lady
you got a beautiful little [ __ ] kid
maker right there if you want it
you ain't even bustin out you're out I
built two in the [ __ ] factory did you
really yeah Wow did you freeze your eggs
no I thought about it yeah freeze that
lady's example so you can respect be a
gentleman I'll freeze the [ __ ] out of
there lay him in the snow in a tunnel oh
my god what if you guys made a snow
child that was incubated in the snow is
a beautiful and I could see you doing
the whole Eskimos bro huh
they're called Eskimos are they yeah man
really yeah okay
Asians born in the Mose they call them
yeah
Mose yeah it's not us not a racial term
but it's a slang term press
[Music]